well you know we talked to a lot of
people for uh my film what is a woman
which is streaming now exclusively on
the daily wire and you go to
wonderswoman.com and get signed up and
you can watch the film right now many of
the conversations we had were
unintentionally hilarious many were
disturbing veering significantly over to
the disturbing end of the spectrum is my
interview with dr michelle
forcier who is as you'll hear her
proudly identify herself a gender
affirming pediatrician also an
abortionist uh we flew up to
providence rhode island uh to speak with
dr forcier she was
you know friendly enough at first and
what we found in many of the interviews
that you'll see in what is a woman is
that gender ideologues are very polite
and nice
right up until the moment when you
express any skepticism
at all but before we get to that point
um where things really start to sort of
fall apart let's get to know michelle a
little bit watch
my name is michelle forcier
and i have a medical degree from
university of connecticut residency
university of utah pediatrics and i've
worked for a number of different planned
parenthoods for 20 years i do advanced
contraception and abortion as well as
gender hormones and sort of looking at
the whole sort of schema of gender sex
and reproductive
justice so you've done a lot of work in
this field could you just start by
telling us sure at what age can a child
first
begin to
transition into another gender or
identify themselves as
a gender different from how they were
born yeah well i mean there's there's
research and data that show that um
babies and infants um understand
differences in gender
some children
figure out their gender
really early
and the reason why we are say oh that's
that's interesting or important is
because they're figuring out their
gender identity is not necessarily
congruent with their sex assigned at
birth when the when the doctor sees the
penis and says this is a male
has a sex of male that's a arbitrary
distinction
telling that family based on that little
penis
that your child is absolutely a hundred
percent male identified no matter what
else occurs in their life
that's not correct
so what is gender affirmation care
you're a big proponent of if we walk
through a child
who's sitting down with you is
questioning yeah their gender what's the
gender affirmation process
affirmation means that as a pediatrician
as someone who says my job is to provide
the best medical care for you
is i need to listen really carefully and
how i put it in words for kids so that
they can understand it is tell me your
story where have you been in terms of
your gender and your gender identity
where are you right now
and more excitingly where would you like
to be in the future
have you ever met a four-year-old
who believes in santa claus
says to someone who believes that
a fat man is traveling through the sky
and a flying reindeer at lightning speed
coming down his chimney with presence
yeah
would you say that this is someone who
maybe has a tenuous grasp on reality
they have an appropriate four-year-old
handle on the reality that's very real
for them agreed i agree but santa claus
is real for them but yeah santa claus is
not actually real yeah well but santa
claus does deliver their christmas
presents
well yeah but he's not real though
to that child they are
when i see a child who you know believes
in santa claus and then let's say this
is a boy and he says i'm a girl
this is someone who can't distinguish
between fantasy and reality so
how could you take that
as a reality
i would say that as a pediatrician and
as a parent
i would say how wonderful my
four-year-old and their imagination is
you know one of the hardest things as we
did this film uh especially in
interviewing somebody
like that
is uh not like my instincts just to yell
at them to begin with
but
that's not what the
it's kind of a short film if it's just
me going around yelling at people the
objective here is to ask
questions and that's and that's uh all
we did to the whole film is just is just
uh is ask questions
and let gender ideology essentially hang
itself as the idea
and uh and and to show is this something
that can withstand
scrutiny or not
even just basic scrutiny and what we
discovered is that it can't so what's
happening in that exchange
is first of all she says uh talking
about a child who sits down with her
is she wants to know about their gender
journey and where would you like to be
in the future so she's talking about a
child's like five-year gender plan
but the point i was trying to get across
to her is that
children
don't have a grasp on reality i mean
even if in theory people could choose
their own gender
which they can't but if they could
it wouldn't make sense to say that a
child could choose it
children believe in santa claus
so like what do they know about reality
if if a child is four years old and
believes that not only santa claus is
real but that fairies and dragons and it
lives appropriately in this kind of
fantasy world
and then the boy says that i'm a girl
that claim
exists within the same fantasy world
this is just imagination this is a kid
who just doesn't it doesn't understand
the distinction we fancy in reality
um so how can they make these
determinations but then again as we as
found there michelle wouldn't even
affirm that santa doesn't exist so that
was i was unclear about that also like
are you
do you actually think that santa exists
what's happening but it's it's
as you're talking to these people it's
like your own you feel yourself going
slightly insane
so it was a pretty bewildering exchange
there but it only gets weirder from here
let's keep watching male gametes that's
what makes me male no your your sperm
don't make you male then what does
it's a constellation
in reality
in truth okay whose truth are we talking
about the same truth that says we're
sitting in this room right now you and i
no
you're not listening if i if i see a
chicken laying eggs and i say that's a
female chicken laying eggs did i assign
female or am i just observing a physical
reality that's happening in the world
does a chicken have gender identity does
a chicken cry
does a chicken commit suicide
let's say
because you're talking you're trying
chicken has sex like any like any
biological organisms an assigned gender
but a chicken doesn't have a gender
identity so we assign female to chickens
when they lay eggs we assume they're
female if they lay eggs that right there
will uh go down for me as
maybe one of the most probably
and every other thing make that makes it
on this particular list is also happened
in the film but certainly one of the
most outrageous
uh
exchanges i've ever had with anybody
and of course see this this is what
happens when you start asking questions
to to the to the gender to the proponent
of gender ideology
is um they you know they start
they end up backing themselves into
various corners and they have to
make
um increasingly more wild sort of claims
to get themselves out of the corners
that they've backed themselves into
and so when you're talking about sex for
example
like it's all on a spectrum
and uh sex is something that is as she
says in in our conversation she says
that sex is a assigned at birth
that just like doctors are just deciding
this kind of arbitrarily
well if that's the nature of
sex then what about other organisms
aside from human beings okay we would
also say that when a chicken is laying
eggs oh well that's a female chicken are
we assigning that is that is that is
that just something we've decided that
the chicken is female
or is the chicken female and if the
chicken is female
then that would tell us something about
the nature of biological sex which is
that it's not assigned it is observed
but she can't go along with that and so
she starts talking about the chicken's
gender identity and whether chickens
commit suicide
and it doesn't get much better from
there well last week kim kardashian
announced her new role as chief taste
consultant for beyond meat an
alternative meat maker according to a
bloomberg report this is a last-ditch
effort for the company's survival having
seen an 80 plunge in shares of the last
12 months they say quote kim's ability
to raise a company's profile would be
welcome for beyond meat which is working
to tame waning consumer curiosity about
its products i should have to say this
but i will um fake meat is gross and
eating fake meat is not going to save
the environment also it's a fitting that
a fake meat company would make the
fakest person on the planet their chief
taste consultant so there's a little bit
of
some symmetry and poetry there i don't
like fake things i like the real deal
that's why i've officially declared
myself the unofficial
chief taste consultant for good ranchers
the meat company that delivers only 100
real american meat and for my first act
as chief taste consultant i want to tell
you about good rancher's latest
promotion right now when you go to
goodranchers.com walsh news codewalsh
you'll get two 18 ounce prime center cut
rib eyes free with your order that's a
100 value for free that's promo code
walsh at goodranchers.com
walsh this is a deal you don't want to
pass up don't support crazy people and
their fake me buy from good ranchers
instead
at what age does the medical transition
begin with uh medication so medical
affirmation begins when the patient says
they're ready for it so that could be
a kiddo who is just starting puberty
and panicking because they're getting
breast buds or their penis is getting
bigger and busier and they're worried
about all kinds of masculine changes and
that way puberty blockers which are
completely reversible
and don't have permanent effects are
wonderful because we can put that pause
on puberty just like if you were
listening to music you put the pause on
and we stop the blockers and puberty
would go right
back to where it was the next note in
the song
just delayed that period of time so this
part is apart from later in the film as
we start getting into more of the
specifics here about puberty blockers
and i'm not going to say myself right
now a lot in response to that because
you have to go watch the film
um because as i said we i'm asking
questions and we don't just ask
questions of people on this side we
bring in other people
so there's a there's a little bit of a
back and forth here but
we're gonna get a response in the film
to this claim that puberty can just be
just be you know just pause it as she
says like like music
does the human body
work that way
i mean is is that the way it works
where you can take a drug
to intentionally
um interfere with certain normal healthy
processes and you could take and then
there's there's
no negative consequences at all
just stop taking the drug and pick up
where you left off
which of course the interesting thing is
that even if that was true which it
isn't as you'll see in the film
but even if it was true well then
wouldn't that mean i mean
if a child's taking puberty blockers
to stop their normal development and
then we're just putting it on pause for
let's say five years
and then they decide that okay i don't
want to take this anymore well at a
minimum now they're going to be five
years behind in their growth and
development so even according to
her version of events
like at a minimum you're going to have
stunted growth
and you're gonna have someone who is
behind in their physical development but
actually the consequences are a lot
worse than that
as we uh discover in the film and as we
get into um in this next exchange about
the puberty blockers themselves what are
they
what do they do
uh what is their what is their actual
purpose
uh let's watch that one of the drugs
used as lupron right which
has actually been used to
chemically castrate sex offenders you
know what
i'm not sure that we should continue
with this interview because it seems
like it's going in a particular
direction well you're a medical
professional i am a medical professional
so you don't want to talk about
the drugs that you give to kids or
again
i'm a physician and i use medication
you're choosing exploitive words
drugs i give you i'm choosing a chemical
guys word that was in a dictionary
that's not a correct term for puberty
blocking i could look
you can look it up on your phone it says
medical definition the administration of
a drug to bring about a mark reduction
in the body's production of androgens
and especially testosterone and i'm
saying as a pediatrician
who takes care of hundreds of these kids
when you use that terminology you were
being malignant and harmful i mean there
are some who would say that giving
chemical castration drugs to kids is
malignant and harmful it's about the
context of caring for a child and and
seeing the
the suffering that kids can have that
have not been in affirmative home
situations so that was the part in our
conversation where things got um
things got a bit
contentious but i wouldn't say that that
that's when they started to get
contentious actually what we discovered
in doing these interviews is that um
you know i kind of knew going in
i had certain points in mind where where
i thought okay well when i ask this
question
um it you know things might get a little
bit tense and i kind of know well
because that's that's more of a
challenging question
and what i found so often in these
interviews is that things got tense much
earlier than i originally thought they
would
because there were questions that i
thought would be really easy for the
person that i'm talking to that turned
out not to be easy at all
questions like
uh what's the difference between sex and
gender you know these are like
that's that's supposed to be a softball
but even that things start go off the
rails in a lot of these interviews when
i ask even a question like that because
what we found is that these people these
gender ideologues especially the ones
who are in this
industry
and they're making a lot of money
off of promoting gender confusion
especially in kids
it's that what we found is that they are
not prepared
to encounter any
skepticism
at all they're not prepared to answer
any questions
the only questions they're prepared to
answer are the questions that are not
really questions at all right questions
like uh how
how meaningful is it to you to be able
to help people in their gender journey
like that those kind of questions or
it's just a setup for them to give a
pre-planned canned you know speech
so by the time we got to this exchange
it'd already gotten pretty tense and uh
and of course i asked her about lupron
now this is a drug that she gives to
kids and as we hear from somebody else
in the film scott nugent um who has
experience with these kinds of drugs
personal experience this drug in
particular is a drug it is actually by
definition chemical castration which is
why i wasn't planning on doing this but
i pulled out my phone look up the the
definition of chemical castration she
said she says that chemical castration
that's a exploitative word and i'm being
malignant and harmful by using that word
well
look up the definition of chemical
castration and that is
a puberty blocker
that is by definition when you give a
kid a puberty blocker you are performing
chemical castration on the kid period
and we know that because the lupron
specifically
has been used
to chemically castrate sex offenders
you notice in that exchange by the way
she didn't deny she she takes issue with
the words that i'm using she threatens
to get up and storm out
um she's offended by the by the
way that i'm phrasing it the words
but she never says
oh no that's that's that's totally
incorrect lupron does not do that
lupron's never been used that way
doesn't say that because she can't i
don't have to tell you that gas prices
are really high right now you've
probably noticed yourself every time you
go to the pump it gives you heartburn
well here's the good news there's an
incredible app that everybody who buys
gas needs to know about and it's called
upside because there is a little bit of
upside when you're pumping gas and this
is it my listeners are earning cash back
for every gallon of gas every time they
fill up just download the free upside
app in the app store or on google play
right now use promo code walsh for 25
cents per gallon or more on your first
fill up that's all cash back that you
get into your account don't pay full
price of the pump anymore get cash back
using upside just download the app for
free it is a free app to emphasize and
use promo code walls for 25 cents per
gallon or more on your first tank it's
not just for gas either you can get cash
back at grocery stores another place
where you could use some savings
restaurants and with take out also you
can cash out any times your bank account
or an e gift card for select retailers
and brands all you got to do is download
the free upside app and use promo code
walsh to get 25 cents per gallon or more
cash back on your first tank just use my
promo code walsh now that's code walsh
and then finally of course we get to the
the question which is the question i ask
uh everyone and uh which is what is a
woman and
probably he's not gonna surprise you by
now that she doesn't exactly have an
answer for it but let's uh let's listen
to what she comes up with
so we're going on this journey
boys can be girls girls can be boys men
can be women women can be men
it makes me wonder
[Music]
what is a woman
what is a woman a woman is someone who
claims that as their identity it could
be many things to many people
that was our answer well a woman is
anyone and that was by the way not to
give any spoilers away but
that is
the answer
from the left to the question which is a
non-answer it's the same thing as not
answering at all but that is that is the
answer a woman is someone who says
everyone
and of course to everyone who gives me
that answer in the film i have the
follow-up well a woman is someone who
identifies as a woman what are they
identifying as and around and around we
go
because they don't have an answer to the
question
this is a
medical doctor
who can't tell you what a woman is
i mean this is someone who who
if someone goes to her and says as a man
and says you know i'm really a woman i
want to transition into a woman
she will help facilitate that process
and yet she doesn't know what the word
means
she doesn't actually know she by her own
testimony
when someone says i want to transition
to a woman she doesn't even know what
that means like what are you
transitioning into
she has no idea
as we found over and over again in the
film and that was just a few minutes of
the film um only one person of the
dozens that we spoke to
and i can tell you right now that um
what we heard in those clips there
i don't think any of it qualifies as
quite the craziest thing we heard the
chicken part gets pretty close still not
all the way there there's there's so
much more that you need to see but you
have to go to what is a woman.com and
subscribe to see it um a lot more where
that came from i promise you
go see for yourself what is woman.com
[Music]
well those were all clips from our film
what is a woman which if you haven't
heard by now you go to whatever.com and
you can be subscribed to get to get that
full film you gotta be subscribed for
that but the great thing is over on on
youtube which you're watching right now
you can get all kinds of content all
kinds of wonderful content for free that
we generously offer to you but if you
want to see more of that then make sure
you leave a comment make sure you hit
the notification bell and you hit like
and you get you hit subscribe and you
get all kinds of great content from that
as well okay the end good